for breakfast that was a lot of work i
was terrified
i cannot believe that it worked out
oh yum
[Music]
are you on camera with me
[Music]
i'm beryl and i made a video about
breakfast around the world and in that
video i asked you in the comments to
tell me about what breakfast was like
where you lived because i wanted to try
it
i'm putting my money where my mouth is i
went through the comments
and i picked out seven dishes from seven
countries
for breakfast that i'm gonna make around
the world
this is the breakfast episode part
two this first dish was submitted from
the netherlands
and the main ingredient here is uh
chocolate sprinkles
i'm gonna take out my toaster
put this fluffy bread in
oh i like to put the butter on the
toaster to help it melt a little bit
anybody else maybe bread is ready
not too toasted
some butter on it i guess the butter
wasn't
that melted yet just get
spread it out come on okay
looking that looks good
now we're going to add chocolate
sprinkles
make it look pretty just pat it i'm
going to pat it into the corner
and it's done tada
okay breakfast number one is from the
netherlands and it's called
ha-ha-sla and it's pretty much
um toast with sprinkles so i'm starting
with the
simplest breakfast originally haha
was any seeds covered in sugar and then
they came out with the
chocolate version which is the most
popular
today also i am
matching the dish
[Music]
i mean it's pretty much chocolate bread
what's not to love about this
you know as an american sweet breakfasts
are
pretty common this is still different
from
other chocolate breads only because the
sprinkles have a bit of a crunchiness to
them
and that's just different and it's fun
sprinkles for breakfast though that's
new roger
do you want the other piece oh yeah
[Music]
enjoy all right
day one
this next dish submitted from azerbaijan
is a
tomato and egg omelet so you're gonna
chop up all the tomatoes
and crack the three eggs and whisk them
together
[Music]
you're gonna put some ghee in the bottom
of the pan you know so nothing
sticks put the tomatoes in there and let
them cook
down so that they get all juicy and soft
juicy and soft then you're going to take
the whisked eggs and drizzle them
on top and let them sit there put a
little bit of salt and
black pepper and at the end you just
want to cover them for
i don't know like the last minute and
ta-da
[Music]
okay today's meal is from
azerbaijan and it's called pamidor
imorta which means eggs and tomatoes
it's kind of like shakshuka azerbaijani
style
there's all this tomato juice in this
which is
i'm sorry for people who hate the word
moist but this is a moist
omelet having a late breakfast today
i was at the dentist this morning who by
the way watches these videos
hi definitely something that anybody
could replicate in their home
super super easily
[Music]
clean play club this next breakfast dish
was submitted from russia
it's a type of pancake where the maid
ingredient is tworag which is a type of
cheese
so take out the food processor put the
tv
add an egg sugar salt flour
and then pulse it and blend it this is
the batter
actually the batter needs to go into the
refrigerator for about an hour
so oh it's been an hour so you need a
bowl of flour next to it and you're
gonna scoop the batter
into the flour super super sticky
so the flour helps so that it doesn't
stick to your hands and you're making
little pancakes
that you're gonna then fry in butter
when they're golden brown on both sides
they are ready to serve
[Music]
okay another day another breakfast
and i absolutely love this dish it's
called syrniki
the word cheese and russian is sir and
these are like little cheese pancakes
yum yum i love these
they're so good oh my god
so they're made from this type of cheese
called farmer's cheese which is kind of
similar to ricotta cheese
so they are rich oh my god ocean food
does not get
the accolades that it deserves because i
love
the cuisine personally it's warm
and crispy but the inside is so soft
when i used to live in russia i'll put a
photo up look at me
[Laughter]
i look good anyway i learned how to make
these when i was living there
if you like cheese and you like the idea
of pancakes
then this is for you
[Music]
this next dish was submitted from haiti
there are a lot of ingredients it is a
cornmeal porridge so we're going to
start by putting some cinnamon and a
nice in
water and boiling it then you add the
cornmeal and you don't want lumps so
don't use a spoon like i did use a whisk
add a girl barrel then you're gonna add
all of the milk
the lime ginger then you're gonna have
the sugar
that's a lot of sugar then nutmeg butter
some salt and let it cook a little more
and
it's done
okay
oh my god i
okay when i think about porridge i don't
tend to think of
flavor but this has
literally layers of flavor creamy
tangy savory sweet it's all of it
and it's porridge i mean i hate when
people say that things are an explosion
of flavor but this
is this is an explosion of flavor
this is the type of breakfast you eat it
and you go whoa
[Music]
whoa that was really good
yum yum yum yum yum yum yum
yum this dish was submitted
from colombia it's a soup where the main
ingredient
is milk you're going to pour equal parts
milk
and water into a pot to boil and you
want to stir it and
watch it because this will happen oh
you have to watch it now put chopped
cilantro and green onion into the milk
salt pepper and you're gonna put an egg
in there to poach it
oh look at my poached egg that's it make
it look pretty
[Music]
okay this morning i'm trying
changua which is a type of breakfast
soup
from colombia we actually did this soup
in the
soup around the world video so it's kind
of cool to try to make it myself in
essence it's eggs poached in milk
interesting so the milk
as a broth is actually much lighter than
i was assuming
[Music]
this one dish i was actually the most
apprehensive about
just because i think a milk based soup
it's out of my comfort zone let's just
say that
but not what i expected
it's cool to find something new if
you're somebody who doesn't like
cilantro though this might not be for
you
i love cilantro i don't think it tastes
like soap
this next dish was submitted from
pakistan
it's a two-part breakfast one is a
homemade bread
good luck to me and the other part is
halawa which is semolina flour
and sugar for the halwa you're going to
melt ghee in a pan
and add the semolina flour and stir it
so it toasts
lightly you're going to slowly add the
condensed milk and sugar
add a little bit of saffron some
cardamom powder
and that part is done now it's time to
make bread
we're making puri which is a deep fried
bread i apparently forgot to record so
here's the dough
but then when i had to figure out what
size the bread balls needed to be
there were some issues so brought in my
husband
these are too big phoned my
mother-in-law
and uh once we once we settled on a size
get the
get a flattened piece of that dough into
some deep oil
and it should puff
[Music]
oh my god you can hear my excitement
when it works
and now it's done you're going to plate
the halawa
with the puris and add some nuts and
dried fruit on top
[Music]
i cannot believe i did this
so the hallway is sweet there was a lot
of sugar in this
and the puri is super savory fried food
tends to do that
this is so different from any breakfast
i've ever had
maybe not an everyday thing right but
[Music]
special i'm just shocked that i was able
to make this
bread seems like such a complicated
thing to do
i'm feeling very proud of myself
it was so hot can you see this sweat
stains i was
stressing the texture of the hollow is
super interesting because
it's very soft but at the same time very
grainy
i have no idea what to equate it to none
it's its own thing workload and stress
load
seems like eight out of ten but
enjoyment
10 out of 10. so does that i think it
balances
this last breakfast dish was submitted
from malaysia it's called nasi lemak
and one of the ingredients are dried
anchovies
so i'm going to clean the rice uncle
roger fans please don't be mean i'm
gonna add some
shallots coconut milk and ginger to my
rice cooker
should have cleaned my rice cooker i'm
gonna make a paste now with
ginger shallots and water that's the
sambal base
add that to some oil clean the lens
clean the lens
adding some chili paste stir it in and
cook it
adding tamarind juice some more shallots
and
that's the sambal now i'm gonna
shallow fry some of the dried anchovies
and some peanuts and here i am plating
coconut rice with the sambal the
anchovies the peanuts
cucumber and a hard-boiled egg it looks
beautiful
[Music]
it's the final dish this is nasi lemak
from malaysia it's actually the national
dish there
i mean i'm
i feel like you need to kind of eat it
all together
dang nasilammic means rice and cream
and that's about the coconut rice here
it's like a buffet
on your plate and something incredible
has just happened
i think i like the anchovies i do
i normally don't like anchovies and i
was prepared
you know to not like them in this
i dare say i really like this
they're not as salty as anchovies when
they come out of the can i totally get
why this is a beloved dish i hate to say
it i feel like i saved the best for last
i really like this one it was really
good
my nose is running my mouth hurts a
little but i'm happy
[Music]
okay i've decided that i have two major
takeaways
from this week the first one is that
personally and maybe all of us we need
to be mixing up
our breakfasts more because there are so
many amazing things out there
and the second thing is that i know a
lot of us are feeling
stuck because we are and we can't travel
but food is this amazing way
to travel and i was able to try all of
these amazing new things from
right here in my home and a lot of them
felt very intimidating to start
i'm not even lying before i would film
every time i'd be sitting over there
just like oh god
i'm gonna fail like it's gonna taste
terrible it's not gonna work it's gonna
be stressful
and okay a couple of them were a little
bit stressful however
i don't think they failed i had a really
good time and
i learned some new things about myself
like number one i liked
fried anchovies and i don't normally
like anchovies
i just think you know you can learn
about yourself through cooking and you
can learn about the world
through eating and since you can't
travel
you might as well cook and i would love
it if you guys left me some more
dishes from where you live to try for
breakfast because i am definitely ready
to keep going
and try a few more
you